This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人录制。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难成长》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，而你正与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套坚不可摧的铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须这样做，听听如何去了解。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇特现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字就是数字“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的世纪骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，要相信你的女性朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。在《回溯往事》（The Look Back at It）播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯往事》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. Today I've got another little bonus episode for you guys. So these shorter episodes are a little bit different from our usual deep dives. Think of them as like little coffee break chats where we tend to just unpack a single term, a single theory, a single psychological concept that is probably misunderstood or just thrown around pretty casually. And the goal here is just to give you something that you can kind of listen to on the go, to give you like just enough clarity to be a little bit more confident when you hear these terms pop up, but also just like for your commute when you don't want to listen to like a 45 minute hour long episode, this is the, this is the alternative.
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。今天我要给大家带来另一个小小的额外番外集。所以这些较短的节目与我们通常的深度剖析有点不同。把它们想象成就像是在喝咖啡时的小憩聊天，我们往往只是剖析一个单一的词汇、一个单一的理论、一个单一的心理学概念，而这个概念可能被误解了，或者只是被相当随口地抛出来。这里的目的只是给你提供一些你可以随时随地听的东西，给你刚好足够的清晰度，让你在听到这些词汇出现时能更加自信，但也只是为了你的通勤时间，当你不想听一节45分钟或一小时长的节目时，这就是，这就是替代方案。
Today's topic, though, is one I get asked about all the time, sociopathy. This is a term that is floating around everywhere at the moment has been for a while on TikTok when it comes to true crime content, even like, you. in dating advice and often in ways that aren't exactly accurate. So we're going to talk about it today. What is sociopathy actually mean? What does it not mean? And how does it different from somebody who's a psychopath or a narcissist?
不过今天的话题是我经常被问到的一个问题：反社会人格（sociopathy）。这是目前无处不在的一个词，在TikTok上关于真实犯罪内容的讨论中已经流行了一段时间，甚至在约会建议中也是如此，而且往往并不十分准确。所以我们今天要讨论它。反社会人格实际上是什么意思？它不是什么？它与精神病态者（psychopath）或自恋者（narcissist）有什么不同？
There's so many different distinctions that we need to make. But first things first, sociopathy isn't actually a clinical diagnosis in modern psychology. You will not open the DSM-5 and find. sociopathy listed as a formal disorder. Anyone who tells you that does not know what they're talking about. What you will find, however, is antisocial personality disorder or ASPD. Sociopathy calling someone a sociopath is more so a cultural term. Historically, it was used at times by a psychologist to describe a particular kind of person, but now we call it ASPD antisocial personality disorder.
我们需要做出非常多的区分。但首先最重要的是，在现代心理学中，反社会人格其实并不是一个临床诊断。你不会翻开《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）找到被列为正式障碍的反社会人格。任何对你这么说的人都不知道自己在说什么。然而，你会找到的是反社会人格障碍（Antisocial Personality Disorder），简称ASPD。称某人为反社会人格者更像是一个文化术语。历史上，心理学家有时用它来描述特定类型的人，但现在我们称之为ASPD，即反社会人格障碍。
What does that disorder? What does that come to describe? So the American Psychiatric Association defines ASPD as a pattern of disregard for and the violation of the rights of others. It often begins in childhood or early adolescence. It continues into adulthood and people with ASPD may find it harder to develop empathy for people. They have a lack of regard for social norms. They are often deceitful, highly irritable, have some kind of conduct issue or disorder,
这种障碍究竟描述的是什么？因此，美国精神病学协会（American Psychiatric Association）将ASPD定义为一种对他人权利的不尊重和侵犯的模式。它通常始于童年或青春期早期。它一直持续到成年，患有ASPD的人可能会发现自己更难对他人产生同理心。他们缺乏对社会规范的尊重。他们往往爱欺骗、高度易怒、有某种行为问题或障碍，
and show more erratic or impulsive behaviors. This is kind of what a sociopath is now seen as. Now, because of this impulsivity, sociopaths are often seen as people who are very reactive and very quick to maybe anger or hurt others. It might also be unsurprising that they also have a lot of substance use issues. One survey found that they're almost seven to eight times more likely to meet the criteria for alcohol dependence and 15 to 17 more times likely to meet the criteria for drug dependence. And the prevalence of ASPD in prison settings is incredibly high.
并且表现出更多古怪或冲动的行为。这就是现在人们所理解的反社会人格。现在，由于这种冲动性，反社会人格者通常被视为反应非常强烈、可能非常快就会对他人发怒或造成伤害的人。毫无疑问，他们也有很多药物滥用问题，这也可能并不令人意外。一项调查发现，他们符合酒精依赖标准的可能性几乎是常人的七到八倍，符合药物依赖标准的可能性则是十五到十七倍。并且ASPD在监狱环境中的发病率高得惊人。
The amount of people that you would find who have had interaction with the legal system who would receive a diagnosis of antisocial personality disorder or sociopathy, if you want to use the old term, is around the one in three mark. Or in one study they did in 2001, they looked at 23,000 prisoners. It was one in two. Almost 50% of people who are in prison, we could flippantly call them sociopaths. They would have a lot of the characteristics of this anti-social personality disorder. So that is really what we're talking about today.
你会发现，那些与法律系统有过接触、并会收到反社会人格障碍诊断（如果你想用旧称的话，就是反社会人格）的人数比例大约在三分之一左右。或者在2001年他们做的一项研究中，他们调查了23000名囚犯。结果是二分之一。几乎50%的在押人员，我们可以轻率地称他们为反社会人格者。他们会具有这种反社会人格障碍的许多特征。所以这确实是我们今天要讨论的内容。
This kind of individual who just seems to almost know how society operates to understand it, but not really know how to cope, not even cope, not even know how to act within that system, within a human system of empathy and of kindness towards other people and of respect and regard for other people's feelings. Now, there's another thing that people often get confused with sociopaths or sociopathy, and that is psychopaths or psychopathy. These two often get lumped together all the time.
这种类型的个人，似乎几乎知道社会是如何运作的，能够理解它，但却真的不知道该如何应对，甚至不是应对，甚至不知道如何在那个系统内行动，在同理心、对他人善良以及尊重和顾及他人感受的人类系统内行动。现在，还有另一件事是人们经常与反社会人格者或反社会人格混淆的，那就是精神病态者（psychopaths）或精神病态（psychopathy）。这两个词经常一直被混为一谈。
They are not the same thing. Psychopaths, that was the original OG umbrella term. That was used to describe anyone with personality types that differed to the perceiving. norms. But in the 1930s and 1940s, psychiatrists began to kind of notice that just calling anybody who had a personality issue, a psychopath was incredibly limiting in terms of how they were going to diagnose these individuals and the different expressions of traits that they all had. And so that's when they really started to kind of, kind of like tear apart or kind of delineate the different kind of conditions that fell under this umbrella term.
它们不是一回事。精神病态者，那是最初的元祖（OG）总括术语。它曾被用来描述任何具有与感知规范不同的人格类型的人。但在20世纪30年代和40年代，精神病学家开始注意到，仅仅把任何有心理问题的人都称为精神病态者，在他们将如何诊断这些个人以及他们所拥有的各种特征表现方面，具有极其严重的局限性。因此，正是在那时，他们真正开始着手剖析或划定属于这个总括术语之下的不同病症。
And sociopath, back in that time, was one of them. Psychopath remained, but there was a difference. A sociopath is someone who developed this kind of antisocial personality because of socialization. So because of their upbringing, because of their environment, because of their community, that is why they are the way they are. psychopaths, the theory is they were just born this way. They have this innate trait, which makes them callous, unaware of others' feelings, or just deeply detached, but also manipulative. So historically, sociopathy is about external factors. Psychopathy is about something that is hardwired,
而在那个时候，反社会人格者就是其中之一。精神病态者保留了下来，但还是有区别的。反社会人格者是由于社会化而发展出这种反社会人格的人。所以是因为他们的成长背景，因为他们的环境，因为他们的社区，这就是他们之所以成为现在这样的原因。至于精神病态者，理论上他们生来就是这样。他们拥有这种与生俱来的特质，这让他们冷酷无情、对别人的感受浑然不觉，或者极其冷漠，但也很有操控欲。因此，从历史上看，反社会人格是关于外部因素的。而精神病态则是关于某种深深根植于你体内的东西。随着时间的推移，这些界限变得有些模糊，现在我们有了这个ASPD诊断，通常将它们全盘涵盖。
deep inside of you. And over time, the lines kind of got blurred, and now we have this ASPD diagnosis, which typically covers them all. Now, one other thing to know about the difference between sociopaths and psychopaths, as people are still using those terms around you, is that sociopaths actually can form attachments with other people. They do love people. They do get married because they care about people.
现在，关于反社会人格者和精神病态者之间的区别，当人们仍在你周围使用这些词时，还需要了解的另一件事是，反社会人格者实际上可以与其他人建立依恋关系。他们确实爱人。他们确实结婚，因为他们在乎别人。
Psychopaths, on the other hand, are deeply calculated. They are more likely to be successful. They are actually less likely to end up in prison. And they mask their manipulative traits using human relationships. They will get married. They may even have kids. But they rarely actually have any kind of deeply empathetic and emotional bond with those individuals.
相比之下，精神病态者则是经过深思熟虑、充满算计的。他们更有可能取得成功。他们实际上更不容易锒铛入狱。他们利用人际关系来掩饰自己善于操控的特质。他们会结婚。他们甚至可能会有孩子。但他们实际上很少与这些人建立任何真正深刻的同理心和情感纽带。
The other thing is sociopaths are highly impulsive. Psychopaths are highly rational. So that's really important to clarify psychopaths as well, they will not, you will not find them in the DSM either. It is still kind of a term that is used, especially in forensic psychology and criminology, especially for people who are researching and trying to understand criminal behavior and the causes and the patterns and the societal impact of crimes. But as of right now, like, you could not walk into a doctor's office and say, or exhibit signs of socioeconomic, sociopathy or psychopathy and get that as your label, it's a lot more casual. So why are these words still used, but also why are they so misused?
另一件事是，反社会人格者高度冲动。而精神病态者高度理性。所以澄清这一点真的很重要；精神病态者也是如此，你在DSM中也找不到他们。它仍然是一个被使用的词，特别是在法医心理学和犯罪学中，特别是对那些正在研究并试图理解犯罪行为、原因、模式以及犯罪对社会影响的研究人员而言。但截至目前，比如，你不能走进医生的办公室说，或者表现出反社会人格（socio-pathy）、反社会人格（sociopathy）或精神病态（psychopathy）的迹象，并以此作为你的标签，这要随心得多了。那么为什么这些词还在被使用，但同时为什么它们又被如此滥用呢？
Why do we come across someone who maybe we don't like, who was maybe a little bit mean, maybe a little bit manipulative, and just be like, that person is a psychopath, that person is a sociopath. A lot of it comes down to this thing called language drift. This is when a word starts in one context, but kind of gets stretched until the point where its meaning is completely different from how it was originally used. Part of why the term sociopath has experienced this language drift and has made it into pop culture and our daily psychobabble is because it really does describe the worst of the worst and it sounds really dramatic. It has weight. It has an edge. Calling your ex a sociopath feels more powerful, maybe even more validating than just saying
为什么我们会遇到一个可能我们不喜欢的人，他可能有点刻薄，可能有点爱操控，然后就会说：“那个人是个精神病态，那个人是个反社会人格”。这很大程度上归结为一种叫做“语言漂移”（language drift）的现象。这是指一个词最初在一个语境中出现，但随后不断被延伸，直到其含义与最初的用法完全不同。反社会人格这个词之所以经历这种语言漂移并进入流行文化和我们的日常心理唠叨中，部分原因在于它确实描述了最糟糕的情况，而且听起来非常戏剧化。它很有分量。它很有冲击力。把你的前任称为反社会人格，会比仅仅根据他们的行为进行描述（你知道的，说他们有操控欲，他们不尊重我）感觉更有力量，甚至可能更有疗愈感。当你随后给那个人贴上一个标签并说他们是个反社会人格时，感觉就像是通过给他们的行为模式贴上一个更严重、更广为人知、社会认可的标签，从而让你所经历的一切变得合法化，这会让人们真正感到震惊并退后一步。就像：“一个反社会人格？哇，那太可怕了。那是连环杀手才会有的。”流行文化也在火上浇油。想想很多电视节目，比如《杀死伊芙》中的维拉内尔（Villanelle），《安眠书店》中的乔·戈德堡（Joe Goldberg），娱乐产业实在太厉害了。他们在塑造这些非常迷人、黑暗、道德模棱两可的角色和人物方面极其擅长。然后，反社会人格的标签就被贴在他们身上，以增加故事的悬念。但是，你知道的，
or describing them based on their behaviors, you know, saying they were manipulative. They didn't treat me with respect. When you then give that person a label and say they were a sociopath, it feels like you legitimize what you went through by giving their pattern of behavior a more serious and recognizable, socially recognizable label that makes people really go like and take a step back. Like a sociopath? Well, that's scary. That's what serial killers are. Pop culture has also poured a lot of fuel on the fire. Think about a lot of TV shows like Villanelle in Killing Eve, Joe Goldberg in You, like the entertainment industry is so good. They are profoundly good at writing these really fascinating, dark, morally ambiguous characters and people. And then the label of sociopath gets slapped onto them to kind of add to like the mistake of the story. But, you know,
他们的行为为了娱乐效果而被夸大了。你知道的，跟踪、谋杀、精心策划的阴谋，这些并不总是会发生在患有ASPD或反社会人格的人身上，也就是，你知道的，ASPD是一种严重的疾病。而这些情况下的情况是，当我们看到这些极端的角色描绘并且使用这种极端的语言时，它往往只是成为了细微差别的代名词。你知道，我们真正想表达的是那个人很危险。那个人是有毒的（toxic）——你们知道我对这个词有什么感觉，但那个人是有毒的。那个人可能会伤害你，可能会伤害我，已经伤害了我。由于那种整个局势的复杂性有时很难传达清楚，“反社会人格”、“精神病态”让事情简单多了。这里面还有一些
their behaviours are heightened for entertainment. You know, the stalking, the murder, the elaborate schemes, that's not always going to occur in someone with ASPD or sociopathy, which is, you know, ASPD is a serious condition. And what happens in these situations is that when we see these extreme character depictions and we have this extreme language, it often just becomes a shorthand for nuance. You know, what we really are trying to say is that is that person is dangerous. That person is toxic. You guys know how I feel about that word, but that person is toxic. That person may hurt you, may hurt me, has hurt me. And because that complexity of that whole situation is hard to sometimes get across, sociopath, psychopath, makes it a lot easier. There's also something about
反社会人格的神秘感，让人不断使用它，对不对？它感觉像是对某人行为的一种秘密洞察或解释，否则我们真的无法用言语来形容他们是谁以及他们为什么会是现在这样。当我们能够给某人贴上标签并将其打包为反社会人格时，感觉就像你已经破解了他们为什么会有这种行为的代码。这确实带来了一种释怀感。就像是，这是一个把某人混乱的行为放进去的整洁盒子，让我可以觉得，好吧，我可以，那段关系结束了，
the mystique of sociopathy that just keeps people using it, right? It feels like this secret insight or explanation for somebody's behavior when otherwise we really wouldn't have words for who they are and why they are the way they are. When we just are able to label someone and package them up as a sociopath, it feels like you've kind of cracked the code of why they act the way they do. And it does give a sense of closure. It's like, this is a neat box to put someone's messy behavior into that allows me to just be like, okay, I can, that relationship is over.
或者我不会和那个人在一起，或者他们是一个彻头彻尾的坏人。这让你更容易对他们不产生同理心或悲悯之心。问题是，许多人其实并不是那样的。许多人的行为都有细微的差别。他们在不同的语境中有不同的表现，不是因为他们是反社会人格，只是因为他们是人类。他们有缺点。他们会犯错。
or I'm not going to be around that person or they are this all bad individual. It makes it easier for you to not feel empathy or sympathy for them. The thing is is that a lot of people are actually not like that. A lot of people have nuanced to their behavior. They act differently in different contexts, not because they're a sociopath, just because they're human. They have flaws. They make mistakes.
这也是为什么我并不总是喜欢我们使用这种极端的语言，把某种东西贴上如此强烈的标签，断言他们永远不会改变，并且不再进一步去探究他们为什么会是现在这样。你可能会说，好吧，这有什么不对？如果他们是个坏人，为什么我不能实话实说？我懂，我理解你从哪个角度出发，我也理解这一点。我认为，因为当我们在临床设置中，或者在需要保持其严重性的设置中，真正需要这些词时，它们会失去意义。另外，单单从它可能会造成巨大的声誉损害这一点来看，
And so it's why I don't always like when we use this extremist language to label something as this very intense thing to claim they can never change and to kind of not investigate why they may be the way they are any further. And you may be saying like, well, what's wrong with that? If they're a bad person, why can't I just call it as I see it? I get, I get whether you're coming from there and I understand that. I think because it loses meaning for when we actually really do need these words and we do want to use them in clinical settings or in in settings where their magnitude needs to remain. Also, just for the simple case of the fact that it could do a lot of reputational damage,
不仅对那个人，对你自己也是如此，这也是需要考虑的事情。这也是为什么我们在使用这些术语时应该稍微谨慎一些。但最后的论点是，这些术语的过度使用确实污名化了那些真正带着ASPD生活的人，也就是那些真正患有反社会人格障碍的人，把他们描绘成恶棍，而有时他们实际上非常努力地在纠正自己的行为，而且他们也未必总是对此负有责任。现在，这是一个很难说出口的观点。我确实相信人们要对自己的行为负责，但他们成为现在这样的方式，他们有时
not just to that person, but to you as well, is also something to consider. And is why we should maybe be a little bit cautious with using these terms. But the final argument is that the overuse of these terms really stigmatizes people who actually do live with ASPD, who actually do have antisocial personality disorder, kind of painting them as villains when sometimes they are actually trying very hard to fix their behavior and they also aren't necessarily always responsible for it. Now, that is a hard thing to say. I do believe that people are responsible for their behavior, but the way they are, the way
成为现在这样的方式并不是他们的错，而且极其复杂。有时说，“嗯，那个人是个反社会人格，他们永远都是个反社会人格”，几乎就等于保证了这种情况真的会发生。那是一个自证预言。然而，当我们把它当作反社会特质来讨论，或者把它当作一种人格障碍、一种疾病、一种病痛、一种状况，而不是命运来讨论时。它确实赋予了人们学习同理心的能力，就像你可以学习一项技能一样，并且能够改变他们的行为。这是一件非常有趣的事情，我真的是通过研究这一集才了解到的。患有反社会人格障碍的人实际上确实有治疗选择。尽管他们在监狱系统和成瘾
they are sometimes was not their fault and is incredibly complex. And sometimes saying, well, that person's a sociopath, they will always be a sociopath, almost guarantees that that will happen. That is a self-fulfilling prophecy. Whereas when we talk about it as antisocial traits, or we talk about it as a personality disorder, a sickness, an illness, a condition, rather than destiny. It actually does give people the capacity to learn empathy the way that you could learn as skill and to kind of change their behavior. This is something very interesting that I've only really learned from researching this episode. People with antisocial personality disorder do actually have treatment options. And although they are highly represented in the prison system and in addiction
统计数据中占比很高，但这并不意味着他们当中就没有人真正学会同理心以及如何对人友善。如果你从来不需要学习如何对人友善，你可能会觉得那太不自然、太奇怪了。但对他们来说，这就像他们生来如此以及他们本来就是这样一样。我们要给他们很大的赞赏，因为他们愿意这样做。我知道这听起来太奇怪了。我某种程度上，听起来确实像是在为反社会人格或任何反社会特质辩护，但我对这些人没有同理心这件事确实感到同理心。就像，如果你大脑中刚好有那么一部分真的无法运作，要做对决定将会非常困难。然后要想让你大脑的那一部分
statistics, it doesn't mean that some of them don't actually learn empathy and learn how to be kind to people. And if you've never had to learn how to be kind to people, you might think that's just like so unnatural and weird. But for them, it's just like how they were born and how they are. And there's a lot of credit to be given to them that they are willing to do that. And I know it sounds so strange. I'm kind of, it does sound like I'm justifying sociopathy or anything. And anti-social traits, but I do have empathy for these people that they don't have empathy. Like, it would be very hard to make the right decisions if you just had this part of your brain that just genuinely didn't work. And it would be very hard to then want that part of your brain
被激活，也会非常困难。有时我希望自己没有同理心。老实说，有时候这真的很糟糕。我确信如果你是一个非常敏感或富有同理心的人，你会理解我的感受，就像你希望自己不必在意一切、不在意每一个人、不在意世界上正在发生的每一场悲剧一样。你希望自己不会吸收别人的情绪，但你确实吸收了，而那是一份天赋。如果你本来就不知道该如何做到这一点或者天生不是这样，要承担起这一切将是非常困难的。好了，我们要稍作休息，然后我们要讨论这种状况实际上是如何产生的、它来自何处，以及我们之前讨论过的一些治疗选择是什么。所以非常兴奋能深入探讨。请留在我们身边，我们将在
to be switched on. Sometimes I wish I didn't have empathy. I honestly, it kind of sucks sometimes. I'm sure that if you're a very sensitive or empathetic person, you will understand where I'm coming from where it's like you wish you didn't have to care about everything and everyone and every tragedy that was going on in the world. You wish you didn't absorb other people's emotions, but you do and that's a gift. And it would be very hard to take on if you didn't already know how to do that or weren't born that way. Okay, we're going to take a short break and then we're going to talk about how this condition actually emerges where it comes from and what some of those treatment options are that we spoke about before. So super excited to get into it. Stay with us. We'll be
这段简短的休息后马上回来。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在当今这个奇特现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，透过那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
right back after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字就是数字“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，畅谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。澄清一下，84年对我的意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊80年代的快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论快克了。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
所以我开始看到其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯往事》。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们在盯着生活记分牌，生活变成了关于赢输的游戏，
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你发现作为一个好人很重要，当你活在世上时，还是说你成为一个好人是因为你害怕，因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟，绝对是的，那是两个不同级别的信任。我希望你们真正成为一个好人。加入我的新播客《艰难成长》，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难成长》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Keer games is we have real conversations about healing growth fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity
随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
女士们先生们，突发新闻。亚利桑那州马里科帕县，劳拉·欧文斯已被大陪审团以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。好了，我们回来继续讨论反社会人格，这是每个人最喜欢的话题。所以反社会人格者、患有ASPD的人，他们确实在我们中间走动。但究竟是什么让他们变成这样的呢？因为老实说，直到最近我们其实都并不是真的知道。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. America Copa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back talking about sociopaths, everybody's favorite topic. So sociopaths, people with ASPD, they do walk among us. But what makes them like this? because honestly, we actually didn't really know until recently.
所以我们之前提到过的一点是，反社会人格者、ASPD——我知道我一直在两者之间切换，我们就简称反社会人格者。反社会人格者，人们认为他们缺乏同理心是环境和社会的产物，也就是说，这是从早期的经历中学习或习得的。这也归结为情绪调节。反社会人格或ASPD研究的一个关键时刻发生在2000年代和2010年代，当时心理学家真正能够弄清其中的机制，正是这种机制意味着这些个人即使在他们想要的时候，或者即使在伤害了别人的时候，也无法控制自己的冲动。
So something we mentioned before is that sociopaths, ASPD, I know I keep going back and forth between them, we'll just say sociopaths. Sociopaths, it's believed that their lack of empathy is environmental and social, so it was learnt or conditioned from early experiences. It also comes down to emotional regulation, a pivotal moment for. for sociopathy or ASPD research came in like the 2000s and the 2010s where psychologists were really able to get down to the mechanism that meant that these individuals could not control their impulses even when they wanted to or even when it was hurting people.
他们发现的是，神经学研究发现，在反社会人格者的脑海中，参与情绪和自我控制的区域的活动非常、非常有限，大大减少了。这尤其体现在前额叶皮层和杏仁核中。这些区域的神经通路基本上处于未被使用和发育不良的状态。这些人没有在关键节点学会如何使用他们大脑的这些区域。他们的大脑可能出于生存原因或其他任何原因不需要这些区域或者关闭了它们。所以如今，作为一个成年人，他们是冲动的。他们反应强烈。他们容易情绪爆发。他们的同理心有所下降。双胞胎和基因研究也提供了
And what they found was that studies, neurological studies found that in the brains of people with sociopathy, the regions that were involved in emotion and self-control had very, very limited, very reduced activity. This was particularly in the prefrontal cortex and the amygdala. The neural pathways in those areas seemed basically unused and underdeveloped. These people had not learnt at a pivotal point how to use these areas of their brain. Their brain maybe didn't need them or shut them off for survival reasons or for whatever it was. And so nowadays, as an adult, they are impulsive. They are reactive. They are prone to emotional outbursts. They have that reduction in empathy. Twin and genetic studies also provide
一些洞察，解释为什么这些模式可能会出现。研究表明，与反社会人格相关的特质既受基因影响，但又是被环境激活的。所以这意味着什么呢？这意味着许多最终发展出ASPD或反社会人格的人，他们体内一直都存在基因倾向。基本上，他们大脑中有一个开关一开始就在那里，它总是会一直在那儿，
some insight into why these patterns might emerge. Researchers show that traits associated with sociopathy are influenced both by genetics, but they are switched on by environment. So what does that mean? That means that a lot of people who go on to develop ASPD or sociopathy, they always were going to have a genetic predisposition. Basically, there was a switch in their brain that started off that was always going to be there,
然后环境中的某些东西把它打开了。现在，问题是，有些人，这个基因永远不会被打开。他们过着非常美好、快乐的生活。他们在童年中非常快乐并被爱着。所以这些反社会人格特质从未显现。但正是当某人经历了童年创伤、忽视、不一致的育儿方式、欺凌时，
and then something in the environment turned it on. Now, the thing is, there are people, for whom that gene will never be turned on. They have a really great happy life. They go through childhood being very happy and being loved. And so these sociopathic traits never emerge. But it's when someone endured childhood trauma, neglect, inconsistent parenting, bullying,
基本上它就被激活了。所以有人介入并说，好吧，是时候了。我们现在要使用这个了。许多人认为，是的，人们生来就有这个，但它确实是由你成长过程中的环境塑造并受其影响的。你可能在想，（你知道的）为什么这些人就不能学习呢？因为我提到过，（你知道的）难道人们就不能学习同理心吗？为什么他们就不能学习不去伤害别人呢？为什么有这么多的个人在监狱里或应对成瘾问题，而没有人足够早地抓住他们，让他们从错误中吸取教训，特别是早期的法律系统？
that basically it's switched on. So someone's come along and gone, all right, time for this. We're going to use this now. Many people believe that, yes, people are born with this, but it really takes shape and is influenced by your environment growing up. What you might be thinking is, you know, why can't these people just learn? Because I've mentioned, you know, people can't they just learn empathy. Why can't they just learn not to hurt people? Why are there all these individuals in prison or dealing with addiction that nobody caught suit enough and that didn't learn from their mistakes specifically with the legal system earlier.
我也问过自己这个问题。答案是，大量研究表明，患有人格障碍的人甚至不知道自己患有此病。所以这就是许多具有马基雅维利主义、自恋或反社会倾向的人格障碍的诡计。他们就是看不到。他们自我的一部分保护着他们，使他们看不到自己与他人之间的这种差异，或者看不到这种差异的重要性。他们可能会注意到模式。他们可能会知道自己经常卷入争端，他们在维持工作或关系方面苦苦挣扎，或者他们在做出冲动的选择。但他们并没有
And I also asked myself that question. The answer is that a lot of research shows that people who have this personality disorder, they don't even know that they have it. So this is the trick with a lot of personality disorders that are like Machiavellian or narcissistic or sociopathic. They just don't see it. There's a part of their ego that protects them from seeing this difference between them and other people or seeing that difference as being important. They might notice patents. They might know that they constantly get into fights, that they struggle to maintain a job or a relationship or that they're making impulsive choices. But they don't
必然将这些行为与人格障碍联系起来。很多时候，他们可能会把这归咎于其他人。研究表明，这实际上也与自我反省和情感洞察力的差异有关。许多患有反社会人格或ASPD的人，实际上无法做到我们所说的“心理化”（mentalizing）。基本上就是通过你的情绪如何影响他人来理解你自己的情绪。这也被称为元认知（metacognition），即能够思考自己的思考。对于某些个人来说，这种能力似乎要低得多。另一方面，有些人却对自己的特质有着非凡的认识。以M. E.托马斯（M. E. Thomas）为例，这是一个自我认同的反社会人格者。她写道，他们写道，
necessarily connect those behaviors to a personality disorder. A lot of the time, they might may blame other people for that. Studies have showed that this is really linked to differences as well in self-reflection and emotional insight. And a lot of people who have sociopathy or ASPD, they actually can't do this thing we called mentalizing. Basically, understanding your own emotions through how your emotions affect others. It's also called metacognition, being able to think about your thinking. This ability seems to be a lot lower for certain individuals. On the flip side, though, some people are remarkably aware of their traits. Take M. E. Thomas, this is a self-identified sociopath. She wrote, they wrote,
《反社会人格者的自白》（Confessions of a Sociopath）。我读过那本书。太棒了。他们谈到很早就注意到自己倾向于操控。他们在情感上是冷漠的。他们可以像生活中的成年人那样施展魅力，而毫无感觉。还有所有这些，说起来有点伤感，但有虐待动物的事件发生。她意识到，他们意识到，比如，我身上出了点问题。人们对此的反应很糟糕。而她能够通过评估自己如何能够通过人们对她行为的正面和负面评价来获得成功，从而学会如何在世界上航行。
Confessions of a sociopath. I've read that book. It's amazing. And they talk about noticing early on that they had tendencies toward manipulation. They were emotionally detached. They could charm, like, adults in their life and feel nothing. There was all this, it's kind of sad to say, but these incidences of animal abuse. And she realized, they realized, like, there's something wrong with me. People are reacting to this poorly. And she was able to learn how to navigate the world by assessing how she could get ahead through people's positive and negative appraisals of her actions.
这就是心理学家所说的“掩饰”（masking），即有意识地调整自己的行为以符合社会期望，同时将看似更具分化的特质隐藏起来。因此，这种意识可以存在于一个光谱上。某些个人完全没有意识到这是一个属于他们的问题。而另一些人则具有高度的意识和高度的策略性。心理学界实际上对于某些反社会特质（如低同理心或无畏）是否真的可以在特定语境中成为一种优势存在一些争论。这就是为什么有些人没有改掉它们的原因。
This is what psychologists call masking, consciously adapting your behavior to fit social expectations, whilst keeping seemingly more divergent traits under wraps. So awareness can exist on a spectrum. Some individuals are genuinely oblivious to this being a them problem. Others are hyper-aware and hyper-strategic. There's actually some debate in psychology about whether certain antisocial traits, like having low empathy or having fearlessness, can actually be an advantage in specific context. which is why some people don't outlearn them.
例如，在风险极高的职业中，比如如果你是一名外科医生，如果你在进行商业谈判，如果你在军队中，情绪反应较少有时可以成为一种资产。当然，说出这一点非常有争议。很明显，你会希望有人在做开胸手术
For example, in high-stakes professions, like if you're a surgeon, if you're in business negotiations, if you're in the military, being less emotionally reactive can sometimes be an asset. Though, of course, that is very controversial to say. Obviously, you would want someone performing open heart surgery
时关心他们的患者是生是死，但也许你又不会，因为那样他们就可以做出更多、更合理和正确的决定，而不会受到诸如“天哪，这个人会没事吗？我会弄死这个人吗？他们生存的几率是多少？”之类情绪的干扰。就像，如果一个人纯粹从数学、可能性或环境的理性角度去思考，也许这会让他们在这个环境中表现得更好。这是一个我们简直没有时间深入探讨的辩论。事实上，我甚至认为我甚至不知道该如何切入这场辩论，因为它太反复无常、太复杂了。
to care whether their patient lived or died, but maybe you wouldn't, because then they could make more, the more justified and right decisions without the emotions of, oh my God, is this person going to be okay? Am I going to kill this person? What are their chances of survival? Like, if someone thinks purely in the math or the likelihood or the rationality of the circumstances, maybe it would make them better in this environment. That is a debate we literally do not have time to get into. In fact, I don't even think I wouldn't even know how to get into that debate because it's like so back and forth and so complex.
但这绝对是值得思考的事情。所以我们在这一集里一直在绕着这个想法打转，那就是反社会人格是有治疗方法的。显然，没有治愈方法。但有一些方法可以帮助人们在社交上进行管理、减少冲动、改善人际关系，有些人可以像你我一样完全正常地生活。这些方法包括谈话疗法、心理化基础疗法（mentalization-based therapy），当然也就是帮助人们理解自己的心态，然后将他们的心态投射到其他人身上，
But it is definitely something to think about. So we've been kind of circling around this idea for a while throughout this episode, which is that there is treatment for sociopathy. Obviously, there is not a cure. But there are ways to help people manage socially to reduce impulsivity to improve relationships. and some people can function completely normal as you and I would. These include talk therapy, mentalization-based therapy, so of course helping people understand their own mindsets and then project their mindsets onto other people,
这就像是同理心的代理或B级版本。还有认知行为疗法（CBT），我认为这简直适用于阳光下的每一种精神人格状况。但这种疗法往往绝不仅仅只有一种。而且它针对个人具有极其强的针对性。有些人甚至不会用这种方法治疗患有这种障碍的人，因为他们属于认为这是不可能的阵营。我认为是可以的。我认为如果这是我们拥有的最好的方法，你不如给这个人最好的东西。不仅是为了他们，还因为——所有那些在他们一生中会与他们相遇的人，如果你能教给一个人
which is like a proxy or like a B-grade version of empathy. There's also cognitive behavioral therapy, which I think is literally used for every mental personality condition under the sun. But the therapy is never often just one thing. And it's incredibly specific to the individual. Some people won't even treat people with this disorder because they are of the camp that it's not possible to. I think it is. I think that if this is the best thing that we have, you may as well give this person the best thing. Not just for them, but because like all the people that are going to come across them throughout their life, if you could teach someone
哪怕是正常人天生同理心的5%，那也会让每个人受到伤害、遭受创伤、感觉糟糕、感觉可怕的几率大大降低。但同样地，关于这是否是一个可行的选择，存在着非常非常大的争议。你不能仅仅把每一个具有这些特质的人都关进监狱，并期望社会变得更好，特别是考虑到他们会出狱，他们会学习，他们会进行掩饰，他们会感到更加孤立并更愿意伤害他人。这里面有太多的细微差别，可以追溯到几百年前，关于我们该如何处理那些似乎不关心他人或似乎拥有这种特质的人。
even 5% of the natural empathy that a normal person would have, that is going to make everyone's odds of being hurt, being harmed, feeling bad, feeling terrible a lot less. But again, it is very, very controversial as to whether this is an option. You can't just put every single person who has these traits in prison and expect society to get better, especially since they will get out of prison and they will learn. and they will mask and they will feel even more isolated and willing to harm other people. There are so many nuances to this that has gone back hundreds and hundreds of years of how do we deal with people who just seem to not care about others or seem to have this
哪怕只有正常人所拥有的天然同理心的5%，也能让每个人受到伤害、遭受损失、感觉糟糕和极度难过的几率大大降低。但话说回来，这是否是一个可行的选择，目前仍存在巨大争议。你不能把所有具有这些特质的人都关进监狱，并指望社会变好，尤其是当他们出狱后会吸取教训、进行伪装，并且会感到更加孤立，甚至更愿意去伤害他人。这里面涉及极其复杂的细微差别，数百年来人们一直在探讨如何处理那些似乎不在乎他人、或者似乎具备这种特质的人。
impulsivity towards hurting people. That being said, what do you do if you think that a friend of yours, a family member of yours, a partner of yours does have anti-stombs, social personality disorder is a sociopath. I think first things first, don't panic and try not to diagnose too quickly. Try and see them as a combination of traits rather than grouping them under this label for as long as you probably possibly can because I think it will, again, stop you from panicking and stop you from freaking out and may actually give them the space to to prove you wrong. Also, it's incredibly emotionally charged. You can do a lot of reputational damage, can do a lot of harm to the relationship if you just say, you're manipulative, you're a sociopath,
对伤害他人有冲动。话虽如此，如果你认为你的朋友、家人或伴侣确实有反社会人格障碍，是个反社会者，你该怎么办？我认为首先要做的是不要惊慌，尽量不要过快下诊断。尽可能长时间地把他们看作是一组特质的结合，而不是把他们归入这个标签之下，因为我认为这同样能阻止你惊慌失措，甚至可能给他们一个证明你错了的空间。此外，这带有极高的情绪色彩。如果你直接说你很有操控欲，你是个反社会者，这会对名誉造成很大损害，也会对关系造成很大伤害，
I don't want anything to do with you. But if you genuinely do believe they are, pay attention to the isolated incidents and keep track of them. You know, one-off selfish or manipulative behaviours, it happens in everyone. But if it's persistent over time, If it's repeated deceit, a lack of empathy, impulsive or reckless behavior is a consistent disregard for others' feelings, that's really concerning. And you don't actually have to continue a relationship with this person if this is who they are. Obviously, I believe they can learn, they can change. It does depend on who the person is.
我不想和你有任何关系。但如果你真的相信他们是这样的人，请留意孤立事件并记录下来。你知道的，偶尔的自私或操纵行为每个人都会有。但如果这种行为长期持续，反复欺骗，缺乏同理心，冲动或鲁莽的行为，并且对他人的感受一贯漠不关心，那就真的很令人担忧了。如果这就是他们本来的样子，你其实不必继续和这样的人保持关系。显然，我相信他们是可以学习、是可以改变的。这确实取决于具体是哪个人。
If this is your parent and they're in their 60s, maybe that ship is sailed for them. And the best thing you can do is just accept that this, is who they are, they have no control over this, now it's up to you to decide whether you want to be in that person's life or not. I think if you feel comfortable doing so, asking the person, like, being curious about what it feels like for them might also just help you and help you make a decision and help the relationship. Questions like, you know, what does it feel like when that like big emotion comes up? Or why did you do that to that person? What were you hoping to get out of that. What does feel like when you're embarrassed? What does it feel like when you're angry?
如果这是你的父母，而且他们已经六十多岁了，也许对他们来说已经错过了改变的时机。你能做的最好的事情就是接受这就是他们，他们对此无法控制，现在轮到你来决定是否还想让这个人出现在你的生活中。我认为如果你觉得可以接受，去询问这个人，比如好奇他们对此有什么感受，也可能对你有所帮助，有助于你做决定并维系这段关系。比如这些问题，当那种强烈的情绪涌现时是什么感觉？或者你为什么要对那个人那样做？你希望从中得到什么。当你感到尴尬时是什么感觉？当你生气时是什么感觉？
If anything else, it's just very fascinating to understand their psychology more. We know that sociopaths often don't connect to these social emotions in the same way. So maybe that will help you see them more clearly for who they are without expecting things from them that they're not capable of and you'll be able to make a more clear-cut decision for yourself with that information knowing that they may never learn these emotions or may never connect with you the way that you want them to because they are not able to please like seek some support seek some guidance for more clarity on this talk to a mental health professional who can help you navigate the situation set immediate boundaries with immediate consequences
退一步讲，深入了解他们的心理是非常迷人的。我们知道，反社会者往往不会以同样的方式与这些社交情感建立联系。所以也许这能帮助你更清晰地认清他们的本质，而不是对他们抱有他们做不到的期望，有了这些信息，你会能够为自己做出更明确的决定，因为你知道他们可能永远不会学会这些情感，或者永远无法以你希望的方式与你连接，因为他们做不到。请寻求一些支持，寻求一些指导，以便对此有更清晰的认识，与精神健康专业人士交谈，他们可以帮助你应对这种情况，并设定即时边界以及即时的后果，
because that is like a very surefire way for someone to learn what is is and is not acceptable in their relationship with you rather than betting on them having the empathy to be able to tell they just might not you have to speak it to them like a child and sometimes it is just best to walk away like you're allowed to just be completely team you and completely like I just don't want anything to do with this. And yeah, that's actually okay. You're an adult. You know what's best for you and your emotional landscape. If this is the best decision, you should do it. Anyways, I think that's all we have time for today. I know I said a mini episode. I were at 30 minutes. I'm so sorry. But this topic is just so endlessly fascinating. I wish that I could talk about it
因为这是让某人了解在与你的关系中什么是可以接受的、什么是不可以接受的最确切的方法，而不是去赌他们是否有同理心能察觉到这一点，他们可能根本没有。你得像对小孩子说话一样对他们直言不讳。有时直接走开才是最好的，你可以完全站在自己这一边，完全表现得我就是不想和这有任何瓜葛。是的，这其实没关系。你已经是成年人了。你知道什么对你自己和你的情感世界最好。如果这是最好的决定，你就应该去做。总之，今天的节目时间就到此为止。我知道我说过这是一个迷你节目。我们已经录了30分钟了。非常抱歉。但这个话题实在太引人入胜了，我真希望自己能多聊一会儿
more, but I will leave some resources in the description, including some of the books that I've read about this, some of the YouTube videos that I've watched that are just incredibly fascinating interviews with people who have sociopathic or psychopathic traits. It's just wild to hear how differently their brains operate. But until next time, make sure you're following us on Instagram. Make sure that you are following along or subscribed, whether you are listening on Spotify, Apple, I heart YouTube. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to. and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
不过我会在简介中留下一些资源，包括我读过的关于这方面的几本书，以及我看过的一些YouTube视频，里面对具有反社会或精神病态特质的人进行了极其引人入胜的采访。听到他们的大脑运作方式如此不同，真是太疯狂了。但在下期节目之前，请务必在Instagram上关注我们。无论你是在Spotify、Apple、I heart还是YouTube上收听，请务必关注或订阅。注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你们最喜爱的治疗师和主持人Kear Games带来的《在艰难中学习》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须去使用它。请在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《在艰难中学习》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or website. wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的走出来的人。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的网站上收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们开始自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他绝不能就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode, we pick a year unpack what went down
或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于1979年，对那对我来说是一个重要的时刻，84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。而我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people Listen to Look Back at it
并试图弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家（比如谈论80年代的马克·拉蒙特·希尔）一起熬过那段日子的。84年是一个疯狂的年份，我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请收听《Look Back at it》
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。